an investigation is underway into the
death of a teenager who was on an
amusement park ride in orlando florida
the team fell on thursday night from an
attraction that's billed as the world's
tallest freestanding drop tower
there is no report of safety issues at
the ride is now closed indefinitely
manuel bajorkas reports
before the orlando freefall ride at icon
park lifted these riders one appeared to
question the seat restraints
the ride appears to have only an over
the shoulder harness that locks riders
into place as it descends 75 miles per
hour as it dropped for more than 400
feet a rider came off the seat and fell
to his death orange county sheriff
identified him as tyree sampson he was
14 years old he was visiting
from his home in missouri with another
family here in central florida this
photo published by the daily mail
reportedly shows sampson on the ride
john stein is with slingshot group which
owns the ride
we are deeply saddened and sorry he says
the ride which opened about three months
ago is designed to only operate if
riders are locked in what possibly could
have gone wrong it's very difficult to
say
the way the ride is designed with all
the safety features and redundancy there
shouldn't be an issue workers could be
heard after the incident
icon park says it's doing everything it
can to cooperate with authorities as
they investigate for cbs saturday
morning manuel bojorquez miami